uh i want to start with congratulations
on nightmare alley uh i thought your
work was beautiful um
before we get into that i always like
asking a few sidebar questions if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've shot what is the first thing you
want them watching and why
oh now you're pulling my legs but you
know i think
i'm very very proud of this one but
shaver water is
again
a very very very beautiful and very
powerful move in your
but i think this one i think you should
watch this one
nightmare
i'm very proud of that and you know i
like when it's just getting better and
better
instead of oh i like
i should see a movie i did for 25 years
ago
so
like
i knocked my alley i loved the story you
know i loved the cast i loved the you
know i think everybody did a fantastic
job and of course gail was pretty cool
too
you know he's okay you know he'll land
on he'll land on his feet um
of the stuff of the stuff you've shot
which shoot ended up being the one that
like almost broke you in terms of
difficulty or the challenge of making it
oh
i will say
of course the carnival is so big and you
know sometimes you have wing problems
you have a lot of like
chicken can technology characters but i
think when we shot
in lily's office
you know
kate and bradley you know we have that
feeling about we want to light them very
special you know this old-fashioned
hollywood diva look
and that's
i think that's pretty difficult to do
that because you know you have to be
super precise with the camera you have
to be super precise with the lighting
it's not like some soft light coming in
from one of the sides
so that was a challenge really a
challenge for me
because everything was moving so much
you know and when you're doing a big
close-up of
cable engineers she just have to look
like a billion dollars and i think she
does that in the movie but it's just
the light is so precise you know you
have to if your light is a little bit
off it just looks
[ __ ] it's like
there's no like
sixty percent that has to be 100
otherwise it doesn't work and i think
that was a challenge but it was super
fun to do it and you know gamora and me
was talking about that a lot a lot a lot
and he's the director you know he's not
pushing you he's he's pushing you to do
the best thing you can do but he's not
putting you in that shoot should shoot
you know but just he wants to do it
perfect and i really like that i think
he's
that is fantastic
he does that all the time but he's just
like
he just wants to have those axes looks
fantastic and of course the performance
have to be outstanding
but so that's a big help as a
cinematographer and of course we have a
lot of discussions about the sets with
tamara and the close you know that group
of people around him is like we're
supporting each other very very much
because we are supporting
guillermo and gamer supporting the movie
so it's it is pretty cool
what do you actually wish more people
knew about being a cinematographer
yeah yes i know but you know it's a very
difficult discussion because everybody
thinks there's you know
i think
of course if you understand and i think
that's a little bit of shame because i
think that would have changed and i
don't want to decide to sound like an
old guy that's just sitting you know not
working whatever i just think if a lot
of people doesn't know the power of the
lighting and i think that's a shame
because if you are lighting a scene
correctly or you know there's nothing
let me just say that i don't think
there's anything wrong or right it's
just a matter of taste and what do you
want to do it's like flat lining
is as good as not flat lining but it's
just for my money and especially with
guillermo
it's like we really want to paint with a
light and write with the camera and we
try to do that all the time
and i think a lot of people doesn't do
that
and i don't understand that but it's not
my call
but what i like with guillermo you know
we're just
so upset about having the right feeling
in the scenes and that's lighting of
course sets and
wardrobe and [ __ ] design and all that
but if you you can for my money you can
build the most beautiful state in the
world and if you like like [ __ ] it
doesn't work
so life is like
and
i'm not saying cinematographer is more
important than anybody else it's just
like a very important thing and it's
it's it is um
you need all the help you can get for
the whole from everybody but that's what
i've said before we are making a movie
together it's not like i'm a
cinematographer more importantly but
it's like a team of people they're
working together with
the tracks that game of thrones and he's
working for the movie and i think that's
very important to understand that
everybody is coming into his world and
he's coming into the rush world
and i think that's that is uh
for me is that's the key of
of movie making because i think movie
making is a teamwork and i think that's
super super important
it's not like one person cannot do it
some people think they can but
it is a teamwork you know if the whole
machine is one wheel is not working it's
going to be bad
and i think that's that is scary is so
fantastic to
know where he wants to go and to tell
everybody where he wants to go so
everybody's going the same direction
and i think that you can see that on the
movies
and i think i love to be a
cinematographer it's super stressed now
and then but it's fun to do it
uh you worked with guillermo many years
ago on mimic
did you have any idea when you were
making mimic that he was going to be
such a special filmmaker because at the
time he hadn't you know he had only done
a tiny little bit
yeah he had done this chrono
small mexican movie but i loved that
movie when i saw throne and i knew i
want to work with him
because my scene brothers asked me to do
the movie and then i met him and i saw
cronin [ __ ] this is pretty cool
um yeah i would say you know
he was a young kid those days
and i was younger as well of course
but he was so precise about where he
wants to go and what he wants to do
and of course we shot him on film
everything was much more difficult and
we were shooting
we mean it's a pretty dark movie and i
think
because i was coming from europe you
know i was not too afraid of going too
dark or
what else but we just
find a language there
um
and then we didn't immediately meet each
other for many many years i think it
took
15 years or something like that before
we did a crimson peak
but i was you know the way he was
the way he was loving his creatures the
way he's
what is fantastic with gamers he's just
love what he's doing
you know if the crease is the character
if it's
he's just he wants to do it 100 right
and that's fantastic and that was the
same on mimic
i'm curious when
for the last three films with crimson
shape of water and nightmare alley
what is it like when guillermo does
guillermo call you and say hey i have an
idea how does he present you with the
information about what he's thinking
about doing
crimson peaky called me because i was
doing in a movie in prague
and we have two weeks high 80s and we
just called me out of the blue and said
you have to come to canada so i flew to
canada and
we haven't met each other for 15 or 12
or 15 years
and when i walked i saw him on location
scout and it was like i've been together
with him for like two days before it was
really really weird like hello buddy he
was like yes
it was not like we have to be talking
very very little
on the phones and stuff like it was like
fantastic
and then when we shot crimson p he
talked about shape of water
but it's always like oh i want to do
this by the way story it's not like
and then when we start saving water he
talked about this one
and when we shot this one he's just
talking about a lot of you know you
always have like 10 movies going on so
it's not you don't know exactly which
ones is going to be
uh
the one we are going to do together and
you know
i don't know anything about the future
but it's it's uh
you know guillermo always has a ton of
things in the fire
always
we have so many movies in the vile and
universe and it's and it's great and you
know he's
so passionate about it and
you know we are coming into the movies
very very slowly
you know he has some ideas i have some
ideas but he's like very precise and
then we talk about you know i think oh
let's shoot it with that camera doing
those lenses or whatever and he's
normally
pretty open for all that kind of stuff
what crazy ideas are
well if we're talking specifically about
nightmare alley so you find out that
this is the film he wants to make he
sends you the script he's telling you
about it whatever it may be can you sort
of take me through your process at the
beginning in terms of how you're
figuring out the aesthetic that you're
looking to do how much is it guillermo
saying i'm looking to do this i'm just
curious about those initial
conversations where you're breaking down
the uh you know what you're going to try
to do with the material
yeah you know he's
when i'm coming to toronto you know
the movie's always a little bit in
pre-production you know the productions
are not scouting or making some concept
with him so you know i'm coming over
then especially
nightmare we would stop and we'll stop
and go and stop and go a couple of times
so i have a very very long prep on that
show
um
because he like to have me around
and just talk about everything and
nothing at the same time
and you know it's like let's go down to
to the
to the wardrobe and let's just look at
some colors there and then you know we i
mean
together with him with a lot a lot of
stuff because we have so much prep but
it's not precisely sitting down and
let's talk about that and it's it's a
very very weak and very long
discussion about how to do that and then
i'm saying i think we should go
we should change we should go on lecture
65 on this one because i think
this i could feel there was so many you
know
so much tight dialogue and tight things
for the actors
so i would go elixir 65
big format cameras so the depth of field
was
going away
much faster than comparing to a normal
alexa and you know we're just shooting
some chests uh
and i show him them and he's have some
opinions about that and we do some color
tests as well so i did a lot of camera
test when he was not there because he
did something else and i showed him and
we did some new tests
uh
but like it's a very slow process and
then we're talking to tamara
a lot about
the sets and the colors of the sets of
course
and we talked about you know we want to
go more wide angle this time
we want to lower the ceilings we want to
have this like
excuse me
um
yeah
like solid ceilings we don't want to fly
the ceilings so we see the ceilings and
be
a little bit more low angle and then
more wide angle and we did compared to
for example shaped water
so we have that discussion and talked
about that you know we're talking about
all those things every day so it's a
very slow
way to get into where we're ending and
then but you know he you know
he has some you know where he wants to
go
and i just try to help him as much as he
can
uh did you actually watch any film noirs
with guillermo or on your own
prior to shooting
i was going to say so that was on
purpose to not look at these things yeah
because then you know if you you know i
didn't want to see the old
nightmare alley i saw the trailer for
that i said it looks pretty cool but i
didn't want to see it because it's a
black and white movie and it's
i want to go into his movies
as open-minded as possible so you know i
don't want to have a lot of
you know normally you can just let's see
citizen kane or whatever you know but
didn't of course i've seen citizen came
20 times
but it was not and we are never doing
that we're never sitting down and
watching a movie together because we
want to go that way we want to go
nightmare alleyway we want to go our own
way and talking about you know so
we have these clear
discussions about how it should look but
we're not using other movies like a
reference and it's not because we don't
want to do it but it's not
it doesn't work like that you know we're
using paintings a little bit paintings
now and then but it's not like we're
sitting down
and watching that movie because we want
to go that way
we have never done that on the movie
we're done
did you do you and guillermo i'm
assuming prior to stepping on set and
this is just me guessing
that you discussed certain colors for
certain scenes and certain color yes can
you sort of take me through that process
some of the the aesthetic choices that
you guys discussed and what you wanted
to do
what he's doing normally and i did that
on this one as well he's doing this
concept drawings
for you know one from each set more or
less you know just briefly
a color color palettes
in the beginning as soon as he does that
before everybody's coming on board
with some guys i think he's somebody's
friend from mexico i'm not sure about
that um
so that is a guideline for everybody you
know this should be
that scene should be like that and that
simply should be like this
and then
we um
we're talking about that a little bit
talking when we're getting closer we
just talk about for example the color of
the
the walls you know together with the
production design and know how
she's making all these design decisions
about the callers and and then we're
talking together about should this be a
little bit darker i should be a little
bit brighter because
we are so afraid of
if the world the walls are getting too
bright you know we really like to have
these like dark dark walls all the time
and then for example in lilly's office
we talked
a million times about putting a carpets
down and not covered you know we just
have these discussions about
how it should look and we do that on all
sets
um
and it's
i think it's a fantastic way to do it
so it's not like that's you know
everything is going pretty slow because
camera have some very precise ideas
together with the production designer
about how the set should look and then
we're just coming in and talking about
let's do this darker because then we can
do that with the light and
the skylight indeed it's was like should
we take it i think it was coming in and
out five times
and you know before we build it of
course you just discuss how it should
look
um
and when we're pre-lighting we have a
lot of discussions about that as well
you know how
sometimes we pre-light it we shoot a
small piece of things on on the camera
just so we can see how it looks
we we want to be
on gamer's movie there's nothing oh by
the way or very very very little
everything is designed down to this to
the last details
how do you how do you actually work out
um with guillermo or on your own uh when
the camera is going to track when it's
going to dolly when it's going to
move you know could you sort of talk
about that process is that in before you
step on set you're figuring all that out
or are you guys figuring out some of
that in the moment
we do that and that is very much
up to gamma we talked about
we talked about how the scene how we
should do that and how we are going to
tell the scene and then we are talking
about what kind of equipment we want to
use it is going to be a crane is going
to be a t-bomb it's going to be a dolly
a steady game
but the camera move guillermo is
designing that because he know
exactly what his cutting point is
so you know that is 100 guillermos of
course we are talking about but you know
he's
he's toned to the grips
when we're doing the shot a lot of times
just
drag in boom down go to the right or
whatever because you have this idea
where his cutting point is
and that was especially on the shape of
water was super super precise so he does
that you know of course we're talking
we're talking about it and you know but
he's designing
the camera move because he know the way
he's cutting is so
you know we're never shooting a master
we are always shooting what he needs and
then we're going to the next set
and let's see next setup
so that's 100 cameras
and of course then
you talk about how the light should be
when you know
because the camera's moving so much so
he wants to move the light as well
so it's not getting too flat
i i spoke to guillermo a few days ago i
had a long conversation with him and he
told me
that
some of his favorite
crane shots some of his favorite shots
that you guys did in this movie he
actually pulled out in the edit uh um
and so he
really was honest with me about uh uh
and some of the changes he made in the
editing room based on feedback from you
know filmmaker friends um so what was
your reaction when you know you have
this beautiful shot
uh that you spent all this time on and
guillermo's like yeah it's not going to
be in the movie anymore
i'm not crying over stuff like that
anymore you know it's
i respect him and trust him so much and
that's the same that most of directors
you know they're not doing that by
purpose they're doing it because it
doesn't work
so you know
if it doesn't work it doesn't work you
have to cut it out and i'm not like of
course it's a shame but it's not like oh
i'm
i'm not crying or stuff like that if
they cut it out because it doesn't work
um
and it's just
it is what it is you know i think again
as i said before we are making the
movies together about guillermo
together with a gamer but girl is making
them
he's doing everything for the movie you
know because that train shot doesn't
work it's just because it doesn't fit
into the movie and it's
it's a shame we did
on mimik we did
we shot a fantastic crane shirt like i
think with a thousand extras
in this grand central station in toronto
it's a huge huge huge crane shot with
like a lot of a lot of extras and we are
coming down booming down booming down
and it looks fantastic and mirror sabine
is coming up
and it was like gorgeous and then the
studio caught it out it's like what the
[ __ ] are you guys doing but
it's just what's happening you know
i think that's movie-making it's it is
it doesn't work you have to get rid of
it kill your darlings
sure i think with mimik though it's an
exception because that [ __ ] weinstein
messed with the movie
so yeah that's a difference you know but
yeah that's a good one yeah you know if
gamble's cutting
a scene out or crane shot out or
whatever you know he does that because
he doesn't work he's not
you know he loves all the stuff as well
as i do
it's not like we are fighting too
you know we're not fighting we're making
these fantastic movies together he's
cutting the stuff out if it doesn't work
and yeah i i i was going to say i told
guillermo because he mentioned how many
of his favorite shots he just
you know the what went through this film
in the edit i'm like but feel free to
show it to me you know i want to see all
these beautiful shots but anyway um one
of the things that i found fascinating
is guillermo telling me and i i sort of
noticed it but you know he was more
clear that he wanted bradley in the dark
and to have the light on bradley from
other people around um i think that's
what he said to me i want to make sure
maybe i'm butchering that but like you
know the lights coming off the other
people uh to to light bradley am i wrong
about this is that that's what he said
i think it's
as a cinematographer you know you're
much more practical you know how are we
going to do that where's the light
coming from it's like you know i think
this is a director's talk and when i'm
shooting it i'm much more like
my world is very practical you know i
have to do
the stuff together with him but he's you
know for example when
they're sitting in the hotel room
and you know he's hitting the sofa and
the couch
and the fire behind him coming up
and then he's going around into the room
and he's coming up and that we have this
silhouette a low ankle shot on the
silhouette remember that shot
yes
for my money that's the most beautiful
shot in the movie it's like
and he cut it out from in the beginning
he there was a version that was out and
i was screaming and crying and i don't
think he cut it out because of me
or pretty begging but it was just but
that exactly that
bradley slits from the people around him
but he was like so much in the
silhouette against the ceiling and
it's a gorgeous shot and it's so
powerful because you feel him
the feeling i feel what he the [ __ ] is
in
but you don't see his face and it's so
great i think and he's so proud to
to do that as a director um
but you know
and again that's
something we are talking about on the
day he said let's do it in dark and i'm
a little bit getting nervous like oh
don't really do that and then just going
dark and dark and then it's going to be
fantastic
but you know he has a fantastic vision
and so i'm not if he's cut it out he's
just have to push some of their stuff
into the movie again
[Laughter]
exactly
he mentioned to me that he hopes at some
point uh people can watch this in black
and white whether it be on home video or
something along those lines has he
discussed that with you yeah we talked
about that and you know we shot some of
you know
we thought about them and we shot it but
it was not like
we talked about it but i don't know
where we are going or what's going to
happen
but he talked about it
and i'm sure
if we are going to do a black and white
version it's going to be pretty cool as
well
but i really like i really like
the color version i think it's beautiful
i think all the colors the color palette
this works fantastic and because
if i like to do a black and white movie
we should shoot it monochromatic you
know but i don't think it's possible to
do this just shoot it like there's no
way back shoot it as
real black and white because what people
does is you're shooting in collar and
just pull the collar out
in post but you know there is a
monochromatic camera that can not like
old
old film stock
but then there's no way back
yeah and i i understand both sides i
mean i i think that i listen i want to
watch whatever guillermo wants to show
so if he wants me to watch this in black
and white as one version believe me i'm
going to watch it in black and white but
i also understand there's a lot of
people
that don't want to watch a movie in
black and white and also this movie
looks beautiful in color so it's one of
these you know but i think i really like
the color version i think it's fantastic
so you know i don't it's not like opens
with a shot in black and white i you
know
we shot up we talked about shooting
shape of water in black and white and i
think it was a big
it was good we didn't do that because i
think the collar in the shaver board is
so
powerful a part of the movie and i think
that's a shame here the same here
the color palette he's coming up with is
or we are coming up with is
is a big part of a storytelling i think
the 100 i absolutely agree with you um
so i i do want to know uh obviously
there were shots that you beautiful
shots that you didn't uh that you you
did that didn't make it into the final
movie um
what is your favorite shot that actually
didn't make the final cut do you
remember
no
it's not because i don't want to talk
about it but don't remember it it's just
like we did so much cool stuff
i just remember that scene i talked
about before he's coming from the
fireplace in the hotel room and he's
going up and standing and see look that
was out for a minute and i was like oh
don't you know and then he it works
really well in the movie
um and i love the love for that sequence
you know i really like c lewis i really
like to go to the dark side
but i don't remember what we
of course there's a lot of stuff
there's a big big crane shot we did in
sunsets in the carnival
you know yeah he he mentioned a few
crane shots to me but we can move on
it's not like i don't
yeah no it's not like my heart is crying
you know i think what i've seen is
fantastic no the film's fantastic um
what do you actually think would
surprise people to learn about the
making of nightmare alley outside of the
covet of it all because everyone you
know we all know that it was shut down
for five months or whatever it was
no i think you know
the way we're shooting or he's shooting
it you know it's like we're shooting
some of the carnival
at location then we're moving the tent
into the studio and all the
practicalities you know about
bringing that big 10 into a studio for
the art department
and for myself lighted like it looks
like it should be outside all this kind
of stuff but that's the same on all
movies you know you're just cheating as
much as you can but we want to do
as much as we can in the camera you know
we want to do as little as possible at
green screen or something like
so the camera is built one-to-one
but i think a lot of those small things
it's not a small thing but it's a big
deal to move the tent to the studio
because it's getting too cold out there
and i think
some stuff like that is like you don't
see it because it works pretty well you
know it's not like you don't have the
feeling about oh now we're in the studio
now we're outside
so
i think the whole process about making
it so fluent as possible you know and we
have this
the whole idea we have a very strong
idea from the beginning about we want to
have a lot of smoke and a lot of steam
at the carnival but not between the
camera and the access we want to have in
the background
so on the catwalks
let's build smoke and steam pipes in so
there was something we talked about from
the beginning
and you know i think all that steam or
smoke in the background first time for
example
when bradley is coming into the carnival
first time you have a lot of smoke in
the back
and you don't see it like oh this is
smoke it's just you feel a little bit
unstable unpleasant there it's not like
oh this is weird but it's just it's
giving a
third dimension into the movie or into
the image and i really like that
and that's something we talked about
from the beginning we want to have
steam and smoke on the carnival
i i think it's one of the one of the
things that pulls you in is that sort of
you know the it almost looks like it's
you know you're entering a dream but
it's not you know
yeah you know one idea about the
carnival should be
the carnival is much
the light is the kind of is much softer
and the access and all you know
everything is a little bit
of course against single socialize
single source lighting but you know it's
much more softer light and comparing to
me we are coming into the buffalo world
will be a much more precise and most
yeah much more precise line
if i'm not mistaken you shot the buffalo
stuff first
and then you did the carnival am i wrong
about this no that's why
so what was it like actually i mean
obviously you must do this on a lot of
movies but what was it like specifically
on this one shooting essentially the
third act before you're shooting the
first and second
yeah i think that was small for
guillermo i think that was a
he didn't like to do that he wants to
shoot it
see number one
from my point of view i don't think it's
a big deal you know i just know
where we are going to be with the
carnival you know we have a lot of prep
for the carnival
um
and we have a lot of ideas about how it
should look and you spend some time for
re-lighting or pre-lighting there
um
so for me it's not
a big deal to start from the beginning
from start to start from the end or
whatever but gamer was not crazy about
that uh of course that's performance and
storytelling and all that i understand
but for me as a cinematographer i think
it's
it's it's not a big deal you know
uh
as long as we know where we're going to
do or what we are going to do when we
are coming to the carnival and we have
pretty precise ideas about that
um oh sorry nope
that was not a big deal for me at all
um before i run out of time with you
because i i have like another 10 minutes
i am a i am a huge i want to emphasize
the word huge fan of the john wick
movies and i
i mean i love them and so i really would
like to just spend a few minutes talking
about them because i think your work
with chad is so good
um what just got number fault
believe sir i am well aware like i
i am uh well aware um so i am curious
what has it been like collaborating with
chad on the john wick films because the
thing that i think is so impressive is
that keanu obviously does so much
himself and you guys are able to do
these wide shots where you're you know
you can have the actors doing these
things and it makes this action so it
pulls you in in this visceral way that a
lot of other movies don't do um and i'm
just curious if you could just talk
about making the films with chad
when i i think i've done crimson peak
and the trailer was just coming out
and then chad called me and said
or somebody i think it was not him but
somebody called me and said you want to
go into a job interview in new york with
john wick
and i said what the [ __ ] was john week
you know excuse me language i have no
idea what it was so i flew to new york i
saw of course john week number one and i
think those guys did a fantastic job you
know was like it was like fantastic i
really liked it
so we i came to new york and then chad
say i want to shoot number two like a
bachelor movie
with a lot of action
and of course as a director of
photographer you just sold right away
like [ __ ] that's fantastic so we did
that you know i think that is the gold
or the key to shoot it wide and
beautiful
as wide as we can
and make it like you know that is my
goal with lighting all the time this
carnival you know i want to have the
light as far away as possible i never
have life
of course if you're doing a close-up of
something
i have light close to the camera but
normally all my light is far far far
away
and that's the same but he wants to do
that wants to shoot wide so keanu could
do what keanu have to do
and then
getting into the close-ups for for
whatever reasons super fast because
keanu is running out of speed of course
because you know he's not a stunt guy
and then we talked i think he loved
crimson peak because he loves the colors
you know he just loved this color
palette we didn't crimson peak jeff for
the john week so
we talked a lot about color he really
likes color he won't you know he loves
this happy world
even he's like super greedy and grumpy
but
and then
he likes to move the camera as we did on
crimson peak as well and we do that
until we you know he's he's a cool guy
he's and we can do you know
we talked a lot about there's another
way to work
compared to cairo
because chad is his inspiration is a lot
from around the world
where i feel guillermo is much more in
his brain
but it's just two different ways to work
um
[Music]
and john week you know we can do
whatever we whatever we want to do
because he's so open but like let's do
it this way and you know it is
he's a cool director you know and he's
done
not you know he's done three big movies
now he's fantastic
um i know that with john wick four uh
you guys shot like honestly four
something months of night shoots at what
point does that break
we shot 18 weeks of [ __ ] night
yeah that is
for people that don't realize that's an
awful lot of night shoots like just a
lot
but you know chad is a funny guy i
really like him i love him but you know
he's one of those guys he like
he like when it's paint and it is paint
to shoot night 18 weeks you know i'm
telling you because you're just getting
into like a zombie world you're never
off
you know you're always like in a kind of
something because you're shooting from
you're coming back to your hotel
apartment like six or seven o'clock in
the morning then you're saying you're
half sleeping tablet and you're sleeping
to two
and then you're
going around like like a zombie in your
apartment and then you have a call like
five foot so you're never you know
you're working all the time
and then
it was pretty it was a tough it was a
really top i think
i've never done it before i've done some
pretty crazy long night shoots on
the league of extraordinary gentlemen
that was like we had a long night shoot
as well but this is like 18 weeks i
think that's a record and
you know we did it looks great but it's
just tough it's really tough
and
i don't think our brains is made for
that but
again we do it for the movie
uh
and and uh
but it was really rough it was tough
it looks great you know i'm really happy
about the look but it's just
yeah
well one of the things about the fourth
one unlike the first two or the two that
you worked on previously is this movie
takes place in berlin and paris which
really open up the door it opens the
doors to the bigger world and it also
allows you to get out of new york city
and photograph
all these different things that have not
been in the first three films uh what
can you what can you tease about what
you and chad were looking to do in these
you know in berlin and paris
we want to open up the world of course
but as much as we could but those cities
are very complicated to shooting you
know there's so many many rules there's
so many
things you have to get permissions to do
you know it was i think it's easy to
shoot in new york and i thought it was
difficult to shoot in new york uh but i
love paris you know paris is my favorite
city in the world but it's just very
difficult to shoot there because there's
so many restrictions
then you cannot shoot there because the
people are living there you know it's
just a lot of lot of stuff but we want
to open up the world and do some
some crazy cool stuff and i think we did
that uh and keanu is
amazing you know he's just a fighter
he's just like so much into a team
player
um
so
i think we did a really really good
movie but it's going to be open up the
world for sure
and there's some coming up some cool
stuff
oh i'm i'm very sure um one of the
things about the john wick films that
just blow me away every time is the way
that the stunt performers and what is
done on second unit and just the way
everything comes together to bring this
world to life can you sort of talk about
um helping to craft these action set
pieces that audiences absolutely love
yeah for example in the number three the
motor motorcycle fight then the bridge
you know of course that was like we
talked about that
for day number one
you know
he wants to do this motorcycle chase
and we talk about where should we do it
should you know we talked about that
bridge
um
[Music]
and very very very early maybe the first
week i was on that movie we just did a
lighting test on the bridge just to
figure out how it should looks
uh and then we've decided it looks
really nice but you we want to put those
tubes we have some put tubes on life and
one and a half miles on the bridge
uh and of course that's kind of a
challenge but that's
that sequence was a second unit sequence
um
and we talked about that forever you
know it's just one of those sequences i
cannot explain how we did it because
it's so complicated
uh
but again chad had these like crazy
ideas about how to do it and he pulled
it out again and it's it works so
fantastic but it's a big
split between first and second unit on
this move the last one we have much less
second union
oh so you were more involved in shooting
the action
yeah we shot that much more on main unit
we have a very small second unit on this
one comparing to number two for number
three
is that something that you is that
something that you enjoy shooting those
kind of action sequences yeah for sure
it's super cool it's fun to do it
uh
but when you you know
yeah i like it i think it's great
but and the reason we like to do it much
that's possible on main units because
then
we're doing the way we like it
sure
what's funny though is i spoke to darren
prescott and chad
during the john wick 3 shoot and they
both told me
that they didn't say it was the
motorcycle sequence but they both told
me they were trying to pull something
off that we're shooting soon that we
still don't know how we're going to
shoot
yeah but that was a motorcycle chase i'm
sure because we you know we have so many
discussions about how to do that it was
like it was so [ __ ] complicated
but in the movie it works
extremely well but you know we have a
million discussions about that
uh how to do it how to do the lighting
how much inter
interactive lighting should we have from
the bridge you know it's a lot of those
discussions
um
and derek is fantastic you know he's so
cool so
that works really really well
am also a huge fan of donnie yen
obviously donnie yen is a part of john
wick four and the thing about donny is
he's just such a professional and he
also like keanu likes to do things
himself um can you sort of talk about
getting to work with donnie and maybe
what surprised you about working with
him
i don't think anything surprised me he
was just so professional he was like he
wants to do everything as you said
exactly like keanu those actors that
wants to
do the fight as good as they can and
they want to do as much as possible
themselves
and i'm just like
they're not teenagers anymore those guys
you know they're doing it so well you
know it's amazing i don't you know
it's i don't know how they're doing it
the stunts and the fights and
of course some of the faults is going to
be sitting there best on people but you
know a lot of a lot of the staff that
did themselves
uh
and he's fantastic uh he's so into it as
well he's he just wants to do it himself
he's there for the movie and it's like
you know you meet some people that says
oh let's do that second unit can do that
or whatever just on people but you know
he's so much since you i want to do it
myself
and
it was great to work with him was fun
today i've never met him before but it
was fantastic
and he brought a lot of good good energy
into the moon
because he wants to be in there all the
time
so i was like oh sorry
no a big pleasant to meet him and work
together with him and you know keanu is
just fantastic yeah i spoke to donnie
for a movie that had come out when he
was shooting john wick and all he did
was praise everyone working on wic and
keanu saying how professional everyone
was it was his favorite hollywood movie
that he worked on he just loved it um
no you know everybody we have some rough
days yet because you know we started
we was running into the fall you know
should be shot in some night shoes and
rain it was freezing cold but nobody was
complaining it was just like let's do it
and
it works extremely well he's super
professional and very nice guy
my last question for you as a fan of
your work uh are you getting ready to
shoot anything anytime soon
yeah i'm going to do a remake of
the color purple
that's going to be a musical
and
we i look really forward to shoot that
that's you know
in south south united states
uh when do you start shooting
i think we're going on camera in
mods i think
oh so you're you're knee-deep in prep
right now then
yeah the movie's starting prepping i'm
going over after christmas but right now
the kovit is so crazy you know who knows
what's going to happen
completely
it is just kidding crazy
yeah i have to stop there i'm just going
to say again
i'm big fan of your work thank you so
much for talking with me sincerely
cannot wait to see the new wick and
congrats on nightmare alley you and
guillermo did such a great job fantastic
thank you so much
you